hi there hey Martin
in a previous episode we moved a web
application from a virtual machine to
Cloud run which is serverless and this
reduced the Ops burden yes we did moving
to Cloud run could also be more cost
effective as you only pay when the
application is used right but the
database was still stuck on a virtual
machine should we move to a serverless
database and get rid of that database
virtual machine too yes let's do it
[Music]
the database that we are migrating
drives the studio application
anyone can add and remove items the two
new items are stored in a mongodb
right the application code is in node.js
and used to run on a virtual machine in
a previous video we moved that code to
Cloud run that means that Google handles
the server maintenance and scaling for
us and we could shut down that virtual
machine today we'll make the database
serverless too and shut down the
remaining virtual machine
exactly a serverless database usually
requires less maintenance work and when
the database is Idle we'll pay less also
if our database is on a virtual machine
and that VM goes down our entire
application goes down when I worked in a
startup our database transaction log
overflowed which took down our entire
application and it took hours to get it
running again well that won't happen
with the serverless database the
database virtual machine is currently
running mongodb which is a nosql
database I think we should migrate it to
Cloud firestore which is a serverless
nosql database in Google Cloud all right
I know you looked into this database
migration there what are the steps so
we'll perform five steps export data
from mongodb transform the data
configure firestore
import data into firestore and update
the application code
got it I can run commands from my local
machine or from cloud shell up in the
cloud I prefer Cloud shell because it's
closer to my cloud resources let me open
it in my project
there it is I'm ready uh tell me how to
do the first step
let's do the first step export data
I sent you two commands uh check if you
got them
uh yep let me paste the first one in uh
this seems to set an environment
variable uh I'll copy and paste the IP
address from the virtual machine that
runs mongodb yes that variable mongodb
underscore URI is needed for the second
command which will do the actual export
okay uh the second command you sent uses
[ __ ] export which is part of the
mongodb tools package I installed it
before in Cloud shell using the
instructions on Mongo's DB I'm running
the export command now
looks like that command created a file
opening it now
uh looks like this is a Json structure
yes it is a mongodb specific data
structure we'll have to tweak it a bit
before we can import it into file store
that's the second step
uh we'll we have to write a python
script or similar to do that
no need we will use a scripting tool
called JQ which is like a set for Json a
command line Json processor you can
install it with tapkit oh okay doing so
now
done now run the next command I sent you
it'll do three changes to the exported
Json file it will assign an object ID as
the key and content as the data remove
the underscore ID and underscore V and
consolidate the objects in the array
into a single object okay I'm running it
now
all done it created a new file now open
that file that file is in a format that
firestore understands now it's time for
step three configure file store
so click the hamburger menu in Cloud
console
scroll down to the databases
click firestore
okay uh should I pick native mode or
data store mode here I usually use
native more
the API for Native mode is similar to
mongodb API that means our code changes
will be smaller
got it I'm picking native mode
and here I'll pick a region and then the
database will be created
so while that is running let's move to
step four
import data into firestore
so this step will be much easier if we
use the firestore export import npm
package so can you install that
okay installing it now
looks like it installed successfully
get the file store export import package
needs a service account key to work
properly so let's create a new service
account for this migration
we can delete it once we are done
this answer reasonable click the
hamburger menu in the Google Cloud
console
pick IAM and then service accounts
click new service account
give the new account a descriptive name
like firestore importer
Grant the new account the Firebase admin
SDK administrator service agent role
and uh click done
now that you have created the account
Let's uh download the key for it click
the firestore Importer account you just
created click keys
click add key and create new key
then click create
and the key will be downloaded to your
machine all right all done so now let's
move that key file from your local
machine to cloudshop on the top right
corner you see there's three dots in the
cloud shell
choose upload
and choose file
now select the key file that just got
downloaded
done
now run the firestore import command
that I sent to you
this command will import the Json file
that we created earlier with JQ command
into faster
make sure you set the a option to point
to the key file that way command will
run as the firestore Importer service
account that we just created before okay
running it now giving it a minute to
finish
looks like it's done very good now go
back to the firestore in the cloud
console if everything worked our data
should be there uh-huh I see your data
here in firestore yeah the import was
successful
great now it's time for the fifth and
the last step update the application
code all right uh what do I need to do
Fair
so first install the firestore client
libraries so our code can use it there
are instructions on this webpage okay
opening it now uh we're using node.js so
I'll click that
looks like I need to run npm install
Google Cloud firestore running that
command now
done what's next now it's time to update
the source code to use firestore client
Library instead of the mongodb library
that it currently has so open the file
to do controller.js in the controllers
directory okay I'm opening that file in
the cloud editor now
so first take out the mongodb
initialization code near the top of this
file
and replace it with the firestore code
that I sent you
very good
done
then replace the bodies of the get post
and delete methods with the other code
Snippets that I just sent all right
replacing the get method
replacing the post method
and finally the delete method
you have now updated the application
code so it reads and writes to do items
from the firestore serverless database
instead of mongodb database that was
previously there on a virtual machine
let's Supply the code and see if it
works
okay I will use the deploy command from
our last video
here goes
looks like the deploy finished I'll go
to the cloud run page in the cloud
console and click the URL to our service
there it is it's working yeah good we
successfully switched from a database
running on a virtual machine to a
serverless database now
there will be less operations work our
application won't have to go down if a
virtual machine crashes so we are all
good great thank you for guiding me
through the five steps to do this
migration but I think you forgot about
the sixth step this will be the most
satisfying step of all I think what's
that
I'm going to turn off the virtual
machine running our old database
there one less virtual machine to worry
about not going to lie that does feel
good
thank you all for watching if you have
any questions or comments for there or
me please add them below we read every
comment also if you'd like to hear about
a particular serverless Topic in a
future episode please let us know below
until next time
[Music]